[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo l'émission
de la rédaction pour revenir sur
l'actualité départementale de la semaine
voici les titres de ce vendredi 24
novembre avec qui elle des ateliers
citoyens et député à voisins le
bretonneux jean-noël barrot élus en
marche sur la 2e circonscription des
yvelines a rencontré des habitants du
territoire
objectif leur pays et leurs idées leur
avis sur des thématiques précises il
financement des entreprises est au coeur
des discussions jeudi soir et nicolas
dainville et notre invité fil rouge pour
cette émission le conseiller municipal
d'opposition à la verrière devient
conseiller départemental il remplace
jean michel fourgous fraîchement élu
président de saint quentin en yvelines
nous évoquons avec lui son nouveau
mandat et ses ambitions
enfin dans le reste de l'actualité
retour sur les annonces des manuels
macron devant le congrès des maires
jeudi ou encore l'ouverture de la 33ème
campagne d'hiver des restos du coeur à
travers le parcours de bénévole
yvelinois après le conseil départemental
il y a un an c'est au tour de la région
ile de france de soutenir la société
atos situé aux clayes-sous-bois dans le
cadre de son plan smart industrie la
région vient d'annoncer le déblocage de
5 millions d'euros en faveur de
l'entreprise qui porte un projet de
rechercher et de développement sur
l'informatique quantique
l'an dernier le conseil départemental
donc des yvelines avait déjà soutenu
atos hauteur d'un million et demi
d'euros
ils ont débuté quelques semaines après
son élection sur la 2e circonscription
des yvelines le député de la république
en marche jean-noël barrot organise des
ateliers citoyens le principe les
habitants sont invités à venir débattre
et faire remonter leurs idées en vue
d'enrichir ensuite le travail législatif
du parlementaire à quatrième atelier se
dérouler jeudi soir à la mairie de
voisins-le-bretonneux thème de la soirée
le financement des entreprises reportage
de grégory canal est un auditoire
attentif mais force de proposition hier
à voisins le bretonneux une trentaine de
personnes a pu échanger avec le député
jean noël barrot explications
discussions autour d'une thématique
technique le financement des entreprises
les débats vont nourrir ensuite le
travail du parlementaire
l'assemblée nationale un atelier citoyen
qu'il juge nécessaires pour associer la
société civile à la décision politique
il fallait que cet espace pca tons vert
pour qu'on ait ce genre de discussions
moi je suis très satisfait parce que à
chaque fois qu'on a eu cette
conversation sa discussion
ça m'a permis d'affiner mes positions
sur un certain nombre de mesures ou
d'amendements qui a été discuté à ce
moment là ça m'a permis aussi d'apporter
de nouvelles idées aux débats de
nouvelles idées ont vu des discussions
sur le projet de loi entreprises qui
sera présenté prochainement à
l'assemblée nationale jean noël barrot à
d'ailleurs été associé à alice aguri
ci-haut de l'accélérateur de start up
the family ils doivent remettre leurs
propositions le 10 décembre au ministre
de l'économie et les participants à
l'atelier citoyens apprécient de pouvoir
apporter leur pierre à la construction
de la loi la possibilité de tout à
chacun de venir s'informer et de
communiquer avec des personnes qui peut
être nous semblaient inaccessibles
auparavant ce mouvement de va et vient
entre des techniciens parce que il en
faut incapable d'élaborer une loi
mais je peux avoir des idées exactement
comme tout le monde qui pourront être
utilisés pour l'élaboration de cette loi
prochains ateliers organisés dans une
autre ville de la 2e circonscription
bucs le 25 janvier 2018 est notre invité
pour cette émission avait le profil
éventuellement en parfait pour rejoindre
la république en marche jeunes et
diplômés
il restait pourtant sur sa droite et il
semble avoir fait le bon choix nicolas
dainville bonsoir bonsoir vous on vous
connaissent hurle sur le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines principalement
comme chef de l'opposition à la verrière
vous êtes désormais aussi conseillé est
départementale puisque vous remplacer
jean-michel fourgous qui est a décidé de
se consacrer uniquement à son mandat à
saint quentin en yvelines à la
présidence avant d'évoquer cette
actualité est votre nouveau mandat votre
avis sur ma comparaison avec la
république en marche et ce qu'en tant
que que gêné lui quand vous avez vu la
vague la république en marche quand est
ce que vous êtes dit tiens il ya
peut-être une opportunité est quelque
chose de nouveau je vais rejoindre ce
mouvement ou alors vous n'avez jamais
hésité alors je suis pas un opportuniste
en politique je fais de la politique
pour défendre des valeurs et des idées
clairement la république en marche
je préfère la république en marche au
mouvement de benoît hamon et le mjs en
termes d'économies y'a rien à voir
par contre sur tout ce qui est sociétale
et sur la vision de la france
j'adhère pas du tout à ce qui est
proposé aujourd'hui par emmanuel macron
enquête par exemple il ya des sujets
précis qui vous des nations unies au
sujet de la famille notamment la pma la
gpa même si emmanuel macron sais pas
trop vraiment prononcé mais il est très
ambigu sur ce sujet donc sur ces sujets
là on a vraiment une ligne de fracture
importante et donc voilà magique c'est
plutôt sur une libéral économiquement et
conservatrice d'un point de vue sociétal
donc vous n'avez jamais ticket ou
hésiter jamais jamais pas comme certains
un nouveau conseiller départemental donc
depuis lundi précisément pour le canton
de trappes à 31 ans seulement ce qui
fait de vous je crois le benjamin du
conseil départemental
est ce que ça vous met la pression
puisque c'est aussi un nouveau mandat
c'est un autre niveau j'ai envie de dire
qu'un mandat de conseiller municipal
sont dénigrés évidemment sourire mandat
mais est-ce que ça ça mais une forme de
pression pour vous
pas une forme de pression mais une
grande grande fierté une grande joie est
effectivement une grande exigence il
faut que je sois à la hauteur de la
confiance qu'on me donne
j'aurai un verset d'ailleurs jean-michel
fourgous qui me fait l'honneur d'arriver
donc au procès départementale qui m'a
accompagné jusqu'à présent est donc
vraiment une
une volonté de servir ne servir le
canton canton trappe la verrière
elancourt et puis de servir une certaine
idée du département et de la france
quelqu'un de passionné j'ai envie de
défendre des valeurs parler de la
famille
il ya aussi le thème de l'économie qui
me tient beaucoup à coeur donc j'ai
envie de faire bouger les lignes j'ai
envie de m'investir pleinement sur les
sujets et de jouer collectif avec
l'ensemble des autres conseils
départementaux pour parler de jean
michel fourgous quel est votre rapport
au nouveau président de saint quentin en
yvelines vous avez parlé de vous lever
et dit merci de me transmettre le
flambeau
est ce que ça veut dire que pour vous
c'est une forme de deux modèles
politiques jean michel fourgous c'est ce
que vous inscrivez au sinon c'est pas
d'écouter je trouve que c'est vraiment
une action assez honorable de sa part de
transmettre le flambeau de miser sur la
nouvelle génération de mettre un jeune
oui parce qu'il cumule des mandatés par
le cumul des mandats et il met un jeune
dont il met le pied à l'étrier aux
jeunes que je suis et donc c'est
vraiment une une action très très
importante pour le renouveau de la
politique pour construire l'avenir
donc ça déjà effectivement je lui dis un
grand merci vous parlez de modèles oui
c'est quelqu'un qui est passionné qui a
envie d'innover qui porte des grands
projets j'aime beaucoup l'économie comme
beaucoup l'économie l'entreprise
l'entrepreneuriat l'esprit d'audace la
créativité est donc clairement je
m'inscris dans ses pas et j'ai envie de
faire aussi bien que lui donc il m'a
beaucoup inspiré il continue à amasser
perry continue à me conseiller aussi
pour les années qui viennent donc c'est
une fierté du succès des avec mon binôme
également anne capio qu'il ya aussi
cette taille fibre sur l'innovation sur
le numérique à la conseillère municipale
elle encourt en seniors municipal maire
adjoint maire assure l'éducation et donc
je pense qu'on forme une bonne équipe
avec la région
le département nos trois communes on a
une équipe de choc je l'espère pour
essayer de faire bouger les lignes et
essayer d'être utile aux habitants et
aux territoires
petite question pratique jean michel
fourgous était président de la
commission des travaux infrastructures
et grands projets innovants est-ce que
du coup vous aussi vous récupérez cette
présidence là est-ce que vous avez du
coup peut-être des projets à porter là
dessus à mettre en avant
je vais être très honnête avec vous je
n'ai pas encore rencontré le président
marcel tracto c'était ça ne se fait pas
de facto par contre monsieur fourgous
s'est vraiment battu pour que je le
remplace au sein de l'établissement
public d'aménagement paris saclay c'est
un projet ambitieux ordinaire c'est 20 %
de la recherche française
c'est le cluster à rayonnement mondial
scientifique qui vise justement à tirer
la france vers l'excellence le but c'est
de créer le plus de liens possibles avec
saint quentin en yvelines l'université
voici de versailles saint quentin c'est
ça votre objectif exactement en gros
s'est réuni les entreprises de saint
quentin les campus universitaires et les
laboratoires de recherche vers l'est du
plateau de saclay et donc ça permet de
rayonner oeuvre exode d'excellence et
c'est un projet qui me tient
particulièrement à coeur
j'ai étudié à chaud c'est donc à jouy en
josas qui fait partie de ce grand projet
d'université paris saclay et donc c'est
un des projets qui va me mobiliser et
qui me passionne dès à présent être élu
au département est ce que c'est aussi un
avantage pour la ville de la verrière
que vous représentez quelque part sur
des cellules au conseil municipal et que
ça pourrait faire avancer éventuellement
des projets ou autres ou alors pas
davantage entre les communes alors non
seulement je la représente j'en suis
très très fier et c'est aussi pour moi
une occasion d'aller au département
c'est d'avoir un levier d'action pour la
verrière
il ya beaucoup de projets qui me
tiennent à coeur il ya le projet des
bécanes qu'il faut faire mais de manière
plus qualitative en tout cas j'aimerais
bien qu'on oriente le projet vers plus
de qualité
et puis sur l'éducation il ya des
talents il ya des jeunes qui ont envie
de réussir envie de réussir notamment
dans l'entrepreneuriat j'ai envie grâce
au département de les pousser de les
tirer vers le haut et puis un projet qui
me tient particulièrement à coeur c'est
d'ouvrir une école une école de la
fondation espérance banlieue j'espère si
vous là si vous connaissez des écoles
alternatives qui mise sur l'excellence
qui mise sur la confiance en soi des
élèves et donc si le département
par mon intermédiaire pouvait
pousser ce genre d'initiative sur trappe
ou la verrière où il encourt ça me
ferait vraiment chaud au coeur parce que
c'est important pour l'avenir alors la
verrière vous êtes le chef de
l'opposition depuis les élections
municipales de 2014 où vous aviez perdu
2 à 40 % 40 60 pour le maire de l'époque
alain âge est ce que vous allez rester
autant engagé à la barrière ou alors du
coup vous avez déjà un groupe au conseil
municipal et vous allez laisser un peu
la main à d'autres de vos collègues
alors je vais pas rester autoriés je
m'engageais encore plus et donc c'est un
vrai une vraie ambition c'est parce
qu'on sait que vous êtes très engagé
personnellement dans dans la ville
c'était vous aurez le temps de rester de
la même façon engagée
bien évidemment on a une très bonne
équipe une équipe soudée je tiens
d'ailleurs à les saluer on a une équipe
de compétences et l'objectif c'est de
profiter de ce mandat départemental pour
faire bouger plus de choses à la
verrière donc moi c'est un vrai objectif
une vraie ambition est donc c'est de
m'impliquer encore plus qu'avant que
j'ai pu faire jusqu'à présent en
partenariat avec la maire actuelle nelly
duthu on sait que parfois les relations
qui sont dues au rôle normal de
l'opposition de la majorité sont un peu
tendus vous appelez un partenariat avec
elle vous pensez que ce sera possible
alors on est en république il ya des ddc
retombe de respect à avoir entre élus et
dont bien évidemment je respecte non
d'après madame du tu es communistes moi
c'est une idéologie que je déteste ce
qui est pas du tout
l'idéologie que je défends moi je
défends plutôt l'initiative individuelle
je lis plutôt sur le mérite sur l'effort
sur la qualité de vie donc je défends
vraiment des idées qui n'ont rien à voir
avec ce qu'elle défend y'a rien chez
vous enfin chez elle en tout cas qui
peut trouver grâce à vos yeux ce n'est
que critique de kankan quand elle
propose d'aider des idées par exemple au
conseil municipal
alors elle elle est en place depuis un
an et demi à rappelons le alors vraiment
nous le la philosophie de notre de notre
groupe c'est d'être constructif donc
quand il ya des bonnes actions les
soutiens quand elles sont contraires à
ceux non non non non il faut il faut
être sérieux
c'est vrai qu'un politique défendue à la
verrière est contraire à ce que nous on
défend ses 15 points concrètement coûté
sur l'urbanisme par exemple on a une
vision de l'urbanisme très très
différentes nous on a envie d'un
urbanisme plutôt qualitatif plutôt
respectueux de l'esprit village plutôt
pavillonnaire qui respecte les jardins
qu'ils soient pas du bétonnage de la
gare bécane je pense particulièrement à
ce projet aujourd'hui est à l'arrêt on
rappelle les grands enjeux c'est
potentiellement 1800 logements qui
pourraient arriver sur la vie des
projets à l'arrêt aujourd'hui puisque on
sait qu'il ya mésentente entre
l'agglomération certaines villes de
l'agglomération
et puis la verrière la verrière a
demandé à ce que l'état prenne en charge
le sujet où en est-on aujourd'hui
et quelle position vous soutenez vous
écoutez c'était un projet honnêtement
assez délirant qu'on a découvert pendant
la campagne qui montaient jusqu'à 2200
logements ce qui aurait doublé la
population de la ville
en dix ans de manière massive avec du r
+ 6 je sais pas si vous imaginez donc ça
aurait presque défigurer la ville de la
verrière qui a une image plutôt village
on apporte de la vallée de chevreuse
donc il fallait que ce projet soit soit
nouveau soit amendée et je pense que ce
projet là tels qu'ils étaient
préalablement penser il faisait peur aux
villes voisines séparemment vie de
maurepas de coignières d'elancourt
parce que de nouvelles populations
beaucoup trop interne de congestion en
terme de circulation en termes
d'arrivées de population massifs
il n'est pas aussi aux habitants les
habitants du bois de l'étang qui avait
peur d'être oublié
alors que ils ont besoin qu'on s'occupe
d'eux de leur quartier
il faisait peur aux habitants du village
qui avait peur de nouvelles populations
et d'un urbanisme qui ce qui compte
qu'ils soient pas conformes à ce qu'ils
attendent donc il faut qu'on d'amande ce
projet faut qu'on trouve un terrain
d'entente
je pense que c'est bien parti jean
michel fourgous a envie d'avancer il
faut avancer le président de 50 ans le
président de saint quentin en yvelines
et donc il faut qu'on trouve un terrain
d'entente un accord pour qu' il y ait un
projet né un projet de loi plus conforme
à la qualité de vie qu'on défend sur
saint quentin en yvelines elle nicolas
dainville rester avec nous on passe tout
de suite à l'actualité de la semaine
[Musique]
l actualité cette semaine marquée par le
100ème congrès des maires qui s'est
tenue lundi de lundi à jeudi à paris en
clôture de l'événement le très attendu
discours d' emmanuel macron le président
a confirmé son souhait de supprimer la
taxe d'habitation pour 80% des français
elle pourrait être même supprimé pour
l'ensemble des contribuables
il a également tenu à rassurer les élus
locaux en affirmant que leurs ressources
seraient préservés écouter en réaction
elle les propos de philippe g selon le
président de l'union des maires ruraux
des yvelines c'était dendre c'était dans
notre journal jeudi soir par téléphone
écouter et faire que tiendra ses
promesses
moi ce qui m'inquiète c'est l'alternance
politique je pense que le président da
cruz tiendra ses promesses jusqu'à la
fin de son mandat mais lorsqu'il y aura
alternance
voilà on pourra revenir dessus
moi j'aurais préféré que je souhaiterais
que ce soit inscrit dans le marbre de
manière à ce que les communes en général
et une visibilité à très long terme
aujourd'hui c'est ce qui nous pose
problème ont des projets on en a plein
on peut trouver des solutions mais
n'ayant pas de visibilité on n'ose plus
aujourd'hui
l'entrée de projet nicolas dainville
qu'est ce que vous avez pensé vous en
tant qu'élu local du discours des macros
qui a surtout annoncé stella l'annoncent
principal une réforme en profondeur de
la fiscalité même si on connaît pas les
détails du tout pour le moment
qu'est ce que vous avez pensé de cette
annonce parce que c'est nécessaire déjà
aujourd'hui les maires ils tirent la
sonnette d'alarmé
ils sont alors comme ils disent il ya
plus de moyens il ya une baisse de
notation majeures dont les imiter -90%
la dgf
donc c'est que c'est sans précédent à la
verrière on extrêmement dépendant par
exemple des dotations de l'état qui ne
cesse de diminuer d'année en année donc
pour continuer des services de proximité
essentiel pour les populations les
maires ils ont besoin de moyens
les maires ses 9 ans les mairies ses 9 %
du déficit et ses 85 % de l'effort
global donc il ya une disproportion qui
est importante avec l'état c'est faites
ce que je dis pas ce que je fais l'état
doit se réformer c'est à lui maintenant
de faire beaucoup plus d'efforts et
juste pour terminer sur la taxe
d'habitation c'est une bêtise sans
précédent on est en train de priver les
mairies d'une recette qui est importante
on sait construire à 16 900 mille euros
je crois à la verrière la taxe
d'habitation
si comme le laisse penser emmanuel
macron se seraient tous les français qui
ne paierait plus cette taxe d'habitation
est ce que même si ce n'est pas une
bonne mesure il ya une forme d'injustice
qui seraient supprimés aussi et qui
serait plus souhaitable ou alors vous
êtes totalement contre la suppression
pour moi c'est une forme de populisme
qui a une sorte de mesure qui permet de
plaire à la population mais qui est
dangereuse au final dangereuse pour les
mairies parce qu'elles vont perdre une
partie de leurs recettes même si l'état
s'engage à ces contrées par exemple à la
décentralisation et à l'autonomie d'une
mairie elle sera dépendante encore plus
de l'état 80 % de son budget risque
d'être entièrement dépendant de l'état
pour moi une mairie il faut viser le
principe de subsidiarité on décide à
l'échelon local des choses qui se
passent au niveau local donc faut donner
aux maires les moyens d'agir et de
décider de ce qui est bon pour leur
territoire plus d'autonomie sanaa
portant à plus d'autonomie c'est aussi
ce qui l'a annoncé ce sera ma dernière
question de réforme de la constitution
pour autoriser les mairies à avoir plus
de souplesse les collectivités avoir
plus de souplesse si elle souhaite
fusionner mettre en commun des
politiques publiques ça ça va dans le
sans ce alors même encore une fois dans
le dimanche ça va dans le bon sens mais
le problème c'est qu'il est en train de
faire aussi la métropole la métropole du
grand paris on passe d'un millefeuille
territorial à une pièce montée
c'est à dire oh non on a des espèces
d'échelon qui créent des ddd triplons de
compétences des ampoules à peine les
précédentes d'ailleurs c'est la
métropole régionale moi ça à l'échelle
de la région je pense que la métropole
est trop il fallait une métropole qui
soit la région avec les départements
c'est important condé ce lien entre nos
deux structures
merci nicolas d'intervenants sur le
plateau de tv 78 je rappelle que vous
êtes le nouveau conseiller départemental
pour le canton de trappes est lui aussi
d'opposition à la verrière merci à vous
et bon week-end merci à vous mardi les
restos du coeur ont lancé leur 33e
campagne d'hiver l'occasion pour la
rédaction de tv 78 de vous présenter
deux bénévoles yvelinois engagé alors
pour servir plus d'un million de repas
est cet hiver dans le département
portraits croisés au centre de
distribution de plaisir où ils sont 70 à
aider les plus démunis
portrait signé par camille lambert dans
ce centre des restos du coeur de plaisir
on se prépare à distribuer plus de 2800
repas cette semaine dominique fait
partie des 70 bénévoles de l'antenne
cela fait trois mois casse est engagé en
faveur des plus démunis
étant à la retraite
on a quand même beaucoup de temps à
vivre donc
je me suis dit pourquoi pas aller au
resto donc je les ai rencontrés lors de
la fête des associations de plaisir et
puis deux jours après j'ai démarré
occupe de la distribution
essentiellement de la ramasse quand il y
a
hier matin faire à l'accueil un travail
quotidien pour cette retraitée de 64 ans
cette campagne hivernale est une
première pour dominique et si son rôle
et logistique
il est avant tout humain au début c'est
difficile parce qu'il faut vraiment
avoir le coeur bien accroché parce qu'on
rencontre des catalins assez difficile
certaines personnes qui qui qui
souffrent qui ont suivi des idées des
coûts de la vie de mauvais coups de la
vie et c'est en sortie
donc on est là pour les pour les aider
pour discuter ne sera pas bon parler
avec eux des fois ils n'ont pas besoin
ils ont même discuté dans le besoin d'un
contact social ce contact social c'est
aussi rené qui leur offre il s'occupe de
l'accueil à la personne et des inscrits
les demandeurs d'emploi demandeurs par
donc simplement le téléréseau mon fils
on les aide au point de l'élémentaire
nous on les aide aussi au point de vue
administratif lorsqu'on va inscrire les
gens on va voir s'ils ont tous leurs
droits
lire par exemple l'aide médicale d'état
ou la cmu c
les réductions transports toutes les
aider à régulariser leur situation
je recherche d'emploi on a des gens qui
sur un peu spécialisé dans la recherche
d'emploi faire un cv à établir un fait
écrire avec les gens
franchir la porte des restos du coeur
une étape difficile pour les personnes
en situation précaire qui souvent
n'osent pas venir mais rené a l'habitude
de les rassurer
il a rejoint l'association dont les
années 90 et était même président
départemental en 1998 j'ai un engagement
très riche
beaucoup de gens disent un merci parce
que vous donner mais on reçoit beaucoup
enrichissant surtout celle de la moitié
69 ans donc ça donne quand même beau
2 on a l'impression d'être utile et de
faire quelque chose on n'est pas dans
notre fauteuil à cardete et je pense que
ça fait pour l'esprit pour la personne
est important pour le moment près de 150
familles sont inscrites dans ce centre
de distribution de plaisir durant la
campagne elle devrait être 250 en france
près de 9 millions de personnes vivent
sous le seuil de pauvreté
les restos du coeur cherche toujours de
nouveaux bénévoles et si et si vous
souhaitez aider les restos du coeur vous
pouvez vous rendre sur le site internet
www.restosducoeur.org c'est une question
que de nombreuses collectivités se pose
comment créer un lien intergénérationnel
au sein de la population est la ville de
plaisir pour répondre à cette
problématique et s'est doté d'un plan
d'action concret celui ci rentre
actuellement dans sa phase active et
prévoit notamment l'accès de tous aux
loisirs et à la culture comme l'expliqué
la maire de la ville qui est venu sur
notre plateau jeudi soir extraits vous
avez des des tranches d'âge qui ne se
déplace pas au théâtre
pas forcément par le biais fait la
difficulté financière mais parce que
elles ont besoin d'être accompagnés donc
on s'est dit avec certains jeunes qu'on
pourrait peut-être aller les chercher
faire du covoiturage les accompagner les
inciter à sortir ça c'est dans le cadre
par exemple du théâtre mais ça peut être
sûr des associations ça peut être aussi
sur des cours au niveau de
l'informatique enfin il ya toute une
série de choses qu'on peut faire comme
ça en binôme un rapport à cet accès est
aussi à la mobilité parce qu'il ya des
personnes qui ont des problématiques de
mobilité donc non seulement la ville
accompagne parce qu'elle a mis en place
aussi quelque chose par rapport à cette
mobilité avec un transport mais il ya
des jeunes et des moins jeunes qui
souhaitent participer à ça on s'est
rendu compte qu'il y avait une vraie
chute aujourd'hui au niveau du bénévolat
dans toutes les associations
ça c'est un vrai moyen citoyens de
revenir à l'aide aux autres faire avec
et faire pour les autres
la fin d'année approche et il ya les
cadeaux à faire les fêtes a préparé
aussi et vous êtes peut-être également
sollicité à de nombreux
deux reprises pour acheter des
calendriers pompiers facteurs éboueurs
attention aux arnaques tout de même
saint cyr l'école a convié ses seniors à
une réunion de prévention avec quelques
conseils à appliquer maryline ya piccino
repérer les fausses cartes
resté discret sur ce qu on possède
installer un entrebâilleur des conseils
pratiques de la direction départementale
de la sécurité publique des yvelines une
soixantaine de personnes s'est déplacée
à la maison des familles de saint cyr
l'école mardi soir
le but de l'intervention faire des
cibles préférées des arnaqueurs des
personnes averties d'autant plus en
cette période de fin d'année et sa
traditionnelle vente de calendriers à
domicile donc les facteurs les pompiers
en général on les connaît puisant des
calendriers particulier qu'on reconnaît
on se méfie quand même parce qu'on sait
jamais et ensuite vous avez bien on a
les éboueurs on l'a entendu tout à
l'heure des gens qui se font passer par
des pour des associations caritatives et
qui veulent vendre des calendriers et là
la ligne de conduite se dire ok je veux
donner aux éboueurs donc je donne au
moment où ils ramassent les poubelles et
si je veux donner une association
caritative
je ferai un don soit en ligne sur
internet je ferai un donjon vers un
chèque à l'association
dernières révisions pour les seniors qui
ont pris note de tous ces conseils
on nous a montré les cartes
professionnelles de police qui sont
nouvelles
ils sont pas du tout celles de julie
lescaut de ou de corinne touzet plus d'
arnaque possible à saint-cyr-l'ecole
maintenant que la population est averti
et si jamais vous avez des doutes
la police rappelle de ne pas hésiter à
faire le 17
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo retour
de l'information en direct lundi à 18
heures d'ici là restez informés et
connecté grâce à notre site internet et
nos applications tv 78 bon week-end à
tous et à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]